se oggi state vedendo questo video
reputate vi fortunati perché vuol dire
che siete ancora vivi e anche tu piccola
creatura se è ancora viva
che fortuna una prima di cominciare ma
mista pisciano addosso
facciamo un piccolo facciamo un piccolo
salto indietro nel tempo il 2020 si apre
con un terremoto in messico al quale
segue il papa che schiaffeggia una
cinese
l'australia brucia uccidendo migliaia di
specie animali e distruggendo il nome
tre chilometri di foreste rigacci si
sciolgono liberando batteri preistorici
hanno risvegliato l'allarme da parte
degli scienziati su quelli che saranno
danni climatici irreversibili al pianeta
ma che molti continuano a vedere come
tiro del complotto
morgan si perde e bugo sanremo viene
vinto da diodato è un giallo il caso di
kim jong un che viene dato per morto ma
poi miracolosamente riappare con un
mitra al confine con la corea del sud
e i compiti che non è stato per niente
protagonista di quest'anno contagiando
più di 80 milioni di persone uccidendone
quasi 2 spopola allo smart working le
figure di merda questo legate e barbara
d'urso ci insegna come lavarci le mani
boris johnson primo ministro inglese non
crede nel covi sposa l'immunità di
greggio e poi prende il copy de cambi
idea viene ucciso floyd e facendo
partire movimento blake lively maxter 20
mila tonnellate di petrolio vengono
versati in un fiume la polonia invade
per sbaglio la repubblica ceca angela da
mondello stabilisce che non ce n'è di
covi di è sempre angela da mondello
cambi idea dice che i compiti in realtà
ciò avviene un'esplosione a beirut
le scarpe della leader finiscono su ebay
a 2.500 euro al paio
morgan abbandonata la ricerca di buco
vorrebbe candidarsi a sindaco di milano
trump non accetta di aver perso contro
biden nella break sit dice ciao
nell'europa ma la scozia vorrebbe
rientrare chiudiamo l'anno con fusi da
zone colori vaccini sentendoci tutti un
po emily adesso perché molti pensino che
il 2020 sia finito un pochino come un
libro che adesso poi riporre su uno
scaffale o utilizzare in qualche modo
per pulirti il bus o in realtà
all'inizio di un nuovo anno che lo più
simile alla saga di twilight dove
l'autrice riesce con ogni libro a
rendere la storia sempre più brutta ecco
perché per questo 2021 in modo da farci
trovare già preparati ho pensato di
raccogliere tutte quante le previsioni
fatti e da loro gli esperti
dell'ottimismo partiamo con la fonte più
attendibile in fatto di perdizione
simpson il 20 gennaio 2021 predicono un
attacco di robot da parte della polizia
i simpson ne hanno già beccato 5 quindi
secondo me tra tutte quelle che vi dirò
sicuramente questa qui alla quale stare
più attenti so che il 20 gennaio è
praticamente oggi quindi notizie
positive il covip 19 se ne andrà ma
avremo problemi a trovare cibo e
arriverà un'altra grande catastrofe ce
lo dice quel inguaribile ottimista al
quale difficile strappare il sorriso di
abb a anand 14enne che invece di farsi
le pippe pensa a rovinarci la vita
indiano che ha previsto il comite 19 non
faremo in tempo ad avere problemi di
cibo che un asteroide c spazzerà tutti
quanti lo dicono i sacri testi di quel
simpaticone che tutti quanti vorremmo
avere a cena nostradamus quindi quello
che vi invito a fare sbrigarvi magari
iscrivervi a questo canale attivare la
campagna le notifiche mettere un like
perché capace che domani non potrete
farlo perché l'asteroide visp azzerati
noi aspettiamo così a braccia aperte
padre pio dato che anche lui ha previsto
questo asteroide dichiarando che saremo
come formiche e faremo di tutto per un
tozzo di pane
in realtà io per magna anche adesso fare
tutta una nota positiva in realtà per
tutti quanti voi c'è all'interno di
questa collezione previsioni e viene non
a caso dalla quota rosa che ci fa
tornare secondo me almeno personalmente
una speranza perché baba wanda ci
comunica che questo è l'anno nel quale
verrà trovata la cura per il cancro una
cura che comunque potremo goderci
pochissimo perché sempre baba vanga ci
fa sapere che arriverà un cataclisma con
uno tsunami che ci sciacquato
dai [ __ ] della guerra quindi grazie
baba per questo momento di speranza che
ci ha improvvisamente tolto o
nostradamus tra un calice di vino
faccela vedè faccela toccà la famosa
cena di prima ci informa anche che
arriverà un attacco di zombie da parte
di un professore russo che creerà un
arma batteriologica che sterminerà la
specie umana
i pochi sopravvissuti all'asteroide ea
tutto quello che dovrebbe teoricamente
venire privitera piatti sti grazie a una
crociera che non sono riusciti a
terminare in questo 2020 dimostrano che
è la terra è piatta buono in tempo per
il dolce e nostradamus si informa di una
terza guerra mondiale ragli 26 è l'iran
ma se tutto dovesse andare secondo le
predizioni dei professionisti dovrebbe
essere in realtà una lotta uno contro
uno tra presidenti a pugni perché il
resto non sarà pervenuto i cieli saranno
invasi da fumo velenoso le terre
avvelenate da un fungo micidiale e le
acque contaminate da vermi invisibili si
vedrà anche la colomba in tempo per
pasqua quindi tu la casa della luce
radiante nel pochino come quando metti
il pandoro sul termosifone mentre l'uomo
settimino si allontanerà dalle sue terre
e dal suo terreno il decennio del
vitello d'oro viene chiamato smarrimento
e angoscia avvolgeranno oltre a nina
moric
ognuno di noi ogni cosa porterà
all'elezione ragazzi occhio del sacrario
del vitello d'oro contenente un altare a
satana questo qui ce lo dice il ragno
nero un monaco sotto copertura veggente
bavarese che potrà essere anch'io
potrebbe per quanto mi riguarda il solo
enrico chiunque dopo aver affermato che
il sisma del 2016 nel centro italia in
realtà è stata una punizione divina per
le unioni civili e che sappiamo tra
parentesi essere possibili solamente ad
amatrice don livio mente illuminata
si informa che satana grazie al co vid
19 prenderà ancora più potere sulla
terra effettuando un vero e proprio
colpo di stato da solo in piazza perché
non ci saranno nemmeno più credo
satanisti belle notizie entriamo adesso
in un momento di predizioni più leggere
con un nome che io vi invito a ricordare
nicolas aulla mi raccomando ragazzi
portate a mente questo nome perché lui
veramente secondo me ha la stoffa del
veggente parte subito con ottimismo
dicendo di stare tranquilli perché
comunque entro metà del 2021 riusciremo
a tenere sotto controllo la pandemia
questo vuol dire che satana il suo colpo
di stato dovrebbero terminare più o meno
intorno al cambio di stagione o tutto
agli maglioni metti le socie e
automaticamente satana non è più in
piazza quindi sei sereno aggiunge anche
che un leader mondiale verrà assassinato
e un altro coinvolta in uno scandalo
sessuale tipo l'anno scorso è stato
neanche anche l'anno prima
nicolas questa era abbastanza facile
uscirà un nuovo libro della saga harry
potter a dirlo chi è nicolas how you la
che si chiamerà harry potter e immagino
e i ripetenti non ripetere il bocciato
il principe amico per ribattere il
principale nulla e poi vengono dei
migliori fate sapere qui sotto e tom
cruise o improvvisamente le attenzioni
di nicolas audiola vanno verso tom
cruise
l'attore che avrà un problema di cuore e
questo è grave però aggiunge anche che
non sa se sarà sentimentale o fisico e
lascia così tom cruise praticamente a
scartare trarsi con da mattina a sera
nella speranza di un divorzio sono
sicuro che però scientologi gli darà una
mano e molto brevemente gli dirà di
nutrirsi anche dei suoi stessi ragazzi
fermi tutti basta scherzare perché verrà
messo in commercio un biscotto digestivo
che riscuoterà un grande successo
immagine non salva nemmeno dirvi il nome
dell'illuminato veggente che ha previsto
questo miracolo fornario che sarà
l'incubo dei vostri culi dopo essere
stati in chiappetta ti da meteoriti
robot tsunami e qualsiasi cosa ma kenton
beige un teologo defunto e comunque
prima di andarsene ha voluto dire la sua
sulla fine del mondo grazie a canton che
verrà
rullo di tamburi per mano di
mancavano solamente loro io spero
sinceramente che arrivino a rather c al
suolo prima il problema al cuore di tom
cruise perché vorrei vederlo in prima
linea a mettere in pratica tutto quello
che ci ha mostrato nei suoi film non
contento dell'asteroide che ci ha
lanciato dell'attacco degli zombie e
della terza guerra mondiale in tempo per
un caffettino prima di andare a dormire
sogni tranquilli
nostradamus ci informa che il 25
novembre ragazzi segnatevi la data il
giorno prima del mio compleanno
capacitano lo festeggiamo 2021 ci sarà
un grande terremoto che colpirà le terre
occidentali luoghi ormai brooklyn queens
secondo me gli umani saranno stati
sradicati dalle grandi città un pochino
come peli superflui ai genitali viviamo
queste diete previsioni con due ultime
informazioni la prima che anche
quest'anno non troverete assolutamente
l'amore della vostra vita a meno che non
siate tom cruise in quel caso lo
perderete lo dice guglielmo scilla
chiudiamo questa raccolta di previsioni
rosee con kenton beige hop che prima di
spirare appena dopo averci informato che
verremo rasi al suolo da una specie
aliena ci dice che gesù tornerà una
buonissima notizia per tutti quanti
cristiani però tornerà nel 2028
ma se tutto andrà come previsto immagino
che troverà una enorme infinita distesa
d'acqua salata piena di plancton che
potrà comunque moltiplicare le
previsioni ragazzi per il nuovo anno
finiscono qui io personalmente vi auguro
un buon anno un buon saccheggio e allo
stesso tempo vi auguro di dormire dei
sogni sereni con una bella carabina
sotto il braccio vi saluto con la
consapevolezza che da qui a 365 giorni
non ci sarà più nulla
buon apocalisse ci vediamo nell'aldilà